sudden this this is this is unclear  certainly not ambitious he's maybe  gone for uh black fish not not gone but  it's it's it's dangerous yeah the  night's very bad right yeah  so mama jar off again very exactly  he plays it he plays rook c5 he's  finding all of these very accurate  defense he's playing like a computer in  this game  i mean i would not like to have defended  that position against addy razor but  he's he's playing  he's playing very well right yeah so uh  okay he's he's going for it i i see some  moves but  can yeah okay mommy's been played so  let's keep up and remember  that um this okay sorry they're coming  quick and fast now and that might be  issues no it's just  uh he took rook f5 okay  you know he doesn't have to take it he  could have played rookie chet and then  rook f5 but of course it's  it's totally winning yeah this this is  actually very important lesson for  people like when they are playing  matches